Looking at the main.css file,
you'll notice the anchor tags and
the button tags have their
outline set to none.
So I need to find all of the anchor and
button elements in this page and
give them new focus styles.
This means I need to style
these navigation elements,
any buttons inside the Jumbotron,
and these raised elements.
Because I want my focus
tiles to look consistent,
I'm going to copy each of these
selectors and group them at the bottom.
Next, I'll add pseudo classes for
focus and hover to each.
Finally I'll add some styling.
I'm going to give each element
a red background on white texts.
This reversing effect will really
make the focus buttons stand out.
But I also want to be careful about
just conveying information with color.
Because some of my users may
have a color vision impairment.
Rob will talk about color vision
impairments in an upcoming lesson but
to cater to these users,
I'll also add a text underline.
So there's a bit more visual
indication that something has changed.
Finally I'll steal this fancy drop
shadow from the raised buttons and
apply it to all the elements.
Adding some shadow will also help the
elements stand out a little bit more.
Tabbing through the updated site, I can
now clearly track focus across the page.
My designer's happy, because the focus
tiles fit the look of the site and
my keyboard users are happy, because
they can easily navigate the page.